it's the end of june so this is around
the time we look back at the season
that's just past
time sure does fly doesn't it the start
of the season felt just like
yesterday but we're already staring at
the incoming summer season
how about a trip down memory lane then
yes this season's been an
action-packed one and i'd like to
highlight some of the most amazing
battles that we've been blessed with
however before we start i'd like to
invite you to hit that subscribe button
up there there are still a sizeable
portion of viewers that haven't
subscribed
so i'd like to encourage you to sub so
that you'll be able to get updates more
easily the next time i upload
now with that out of the way let's get
started on our list
shiki versus jin opens up our list at
number 10.
okay
[Music]
coming into this season i'm sure
everyone had varying opinions on eden
zero some were lukewarm to it while
others gladly welcomed another battle
shown into the ever-growing family
personally i liked the idea of the
sci-fi theme of the series and i more or
less enjoyed the series from the get-go
whatever your opinions are i think we
have to give credit where it's due for
the cool fights that we got as early as
a season in
understandably shiki versus jin's
probably not on anyone's radar that
gives me even more reason to include
this fun little scuffle on the list
it's in fights like this that you see
mashima's creativity on display and
despite being a departure from his
previous work in terms of setting eden
zero
still gives us some hints of fairy tale
and rave at their best it's early for
the hype to match anything from those
two
but i love how the technological and
modern aspects of the show are
incorporated in this battle
it's great to see that hiro mashima
still has it in him i admit at first i
was unsure of what to expect of eden
zero adaptation but so far it's been
pretty lit
big prompts to the anime team for making
the most out of the source material and
giving us this fight too
[Music]
when the season started i found myself
very excited for yasuke it's not the
very top but it's somewhere up there in
terms of shows that i look forward to it
didn't really live up to my expectation
but one thing that the show gave me was
some good fights
episode four's battle between yasuke and
guru osaka didn't disappoint in the
slightest
i know coming in that one of the parts
in the show that would be given a lot of
focus on would be the sword fights and
that much can be seen in this epic jewel
the action's fast paced and the art and
animation just looks so clean and smooth
i also liked how the battle made full
use of the setting and allowed the
fighters to make the most of the
environment
before concluding with a dramatic end
[Music]
you know what amazes me about one piece
is that despite running through multiple
generations of anime fans the animation
and the fight still maintain that
consistent quality i don't need any
further proof than the recent fight
which put luffy
law and kid against the beast pirates
yeah i call it a fight
but it's really just the three of them
putting on a show while giving us fan
service in the form of their cool
abilities amongst the three of them
i've always been a fan of law's powers
and seeing it being utilized the way it
did here felt really great
the fight is overall just an extended
flex by our key characters but
it's treated so much better than that
the fight's not much of an epic back and
forth matter but i think that it
deserves a spot here merely due to the
animation quality
seriously it's amazing how encounters
between our op characters and some
fodder gets so much
love in terms of animation quality what
more when we get to the bigger fights
later down the line
i'm pretty excited about that
it's a late coming to the party but we
have a crazy one here record of ragnarok
as an adaptation has had quite the mixed
reception to say the least
however one thing that i can be sure of
is that it provides one of the top
fights that we've seen this season
that's adam versus zeus i think that the
best part of the fight besides the fight
itself
is the message adam represents
humanity's strength and will and despite
being outmatched puts up one hell of a
fight
to further drive the message home zeus
wins on a technicality that's an amazing
show of humanity's inner strength
despite lacking the physical prowess
that gods have
and are really like battles that push
forward that message on another note
record of ragnarok has that fake thing
of using some historical and mythical
characters
in highly creative interpretations you
can binge in one day
so i recommend you check record of
ragnarok out if you enjoy some wacky and
over-the-top fights
i know that megalo box had it in it to
give us one of the most awesome fights
of the season
waiting eight episodes is worth it as we
get to see a crazy showdown between mac
and lu
of course we can count one of the more
underrated boxing animated deliver
it's quite the intense fight we have
here with the fight starting out heavily
in lou's favor i mean i wouldn't be
surprised if some people found the fight
hard to watch
due to how much of a beat down lose
giving out all without restraint
then mac time begins and the tide turns
for me the most important part of the
episode however
was the revelations on what mac time
really is it seems to be a feature
rather than a bug and it sure is setting
up some possible consequences in the
future
plus the entire thing reeked of some
corporate bs
which i think should be a key focus on
the story moving forward
i love these friendly sparring arcs we
just had one in jujutsu kaizen which
became my favorite arc in the whole
thing
and my hero academia is not about to
lose out too the joint training arc is
quite long with a bevy of fights
but my favorite segment would have to be
the one with team eda
taking on tetsutetsu's team this whole
sequence is just a good show of each
hero's abilities and how they use them
against each other there are stakes for
sure but it's not exactly the life and
death battle that villain fights are
but you wouldn't be able to tell given
the passion and effort on full display
todoroki and tetsu tetsu in particular
have a great duel but let's not forget
aida showing off some of the cool new
tricks up his sleeve the joint training
battle is just a fun ride all throughout
and while i pick this set to be the best
one of them the other fights are also
awesome in their own ways
now here's something that i'm sure a lot
of you didn't expect to see perhaps it's
the genre but the dragon quest anime as
far as i can see has been quite the
overlooked show
now while i wouldn't say the show's
anime of the season material or anything
like that
it did provide some hidden gems in terms
of fights such as this one the fight at
first seems to be your standard shonen
fair
not that it's a bad thing in fact it's
very satisfying
and a fight like this seems to be
something that everyone's come to expect
from a series of the genre
however what takes this fight to the
next level can be seen when you take a
closer look at the animation the way the
battle happened
and the animation techniques employed
really reminded me of some of my
favorite fights from dragon ball super
but with the wonders of modern
technology
it seemed like a call back to the stuff
like the broly fighting super or
something from black clover i'm not sure
if the dragon quest anime would be your
cup of tea
but if you like fights in the setting of
the anime do yourself a favor and pick
the show up
and castlevania continues to impress
i've briefly talked about this on a
previous video that despite castlevania
not being a japanese anime i feel that i
want to highlight the show a bit more
because it looks pretty anime anyway and
it consistently gives us
fights as neat as this one carmilla vs
isaac for me is the highlight of the
season of castlevania
the best fight amongst the bunch if you
may and a lot of that has to do with the
fight choreography and how much the
combatants characters shone in this duel
a good fight is also a way to showcase
character development
you know a way to present an extension
of what the characters have been through
in a sense it's been a long run now but
this fight really caps off the great
journey isaac has gone through as a
character
you can also see how he compensates for
the lack of power in comparison to his
opponent and the same goes for carmilla
and her pride being her downfall
you know entering this season i had high
hopes for vivi i just had the feeling
that i'd like it
being the action sci-fi nut that i am
however i didn't expect to get blown out
by the spectacular fight choreography
that the show has
the quality is so insane so much so that
i added a fight as a last minute entry
to the female fights video when i saw it
with the bar set that high so early
what else would be there for me as far
as vv's concerned well
an even better fight of course episode
nine's fight is just
insane that's all i have to say about it
i haven't watched everything this season
but i might as well bet that not a lot
of stuff this season can top the fight
choreography in this one this fight had
me on the edge of my seat consumed by
pure adrenaline
thanks to the camera angles the pacing
and just how sleek everything looks
seriously watch vv i know i can't call
it an unappreciated show or anything
because it does have some hype
attraction
but i think that it does deserve better
the show has an intriguing plot that
fuses elements from a lot of fan
favorite anime with games such as
detroit
become human topped off with by far the
best fight choreography
the season has seen
it's a close call this one it really
really was in the end i decided to give
the top spot to this one because it was
one of the few fights that really blew
up on the internet at least from what i
saw anyway
plus it's not too shabby of a fight to
be fair actually no i take that back
this one is an amazingly animated fight
that reminds me of the previous team up
versus momoshiki pretty much what you
want from a naruto universe fight is in
full display here you've got the usual
abilities of our characters along with a
mix of daijutsu
it's a very tense battle and compared to
the momoshiki fight
the dad seemed to be so screwed this
time round jigen
is just so powerful that he can take on
both naruto and sasuke without even
breaking a sweat
and even the trusty powers that we've
known the legacy characters for
such as the susano seem to be no match
at some point
overall a very great fight that will
serve as a landmark turning point in
boruto for years to come
now those were some great looking fights
weren't they but you know what's not
amazing
region logs well luckily expressvpn is
here to help you
vanquish those pesky region locks with
the click of a button i mean really
it's that simple just open the interface
click your server of choice and voila
say bye bye to those region locks
forever the other cool part about
expressvpn is how well it protects your
data
with data breaches happening these days
and even big time personalities falling
victim to them you can't go
unprepared expressvpn however is your
number one buddy when it comes to
protecting your data and helping you
maintain your anonymity on the internet
surfing's never been safer before if
you're looking for a vpn to use then
look no further expressvpn blows
everything else out of the water with
its ease of use
speed and pure value for what you're
paying if you want to know how to get
started with expressvpn and get three
months for free just follow the link
that i've left you on the description
box or go to expressvpn.com if you
enjoyed the video
make sure to leave a like that'll do for
this edition of the vini tube countdown
lists i wish you a great day ahead and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you